Okay, in Muhamm, nana bahamil i amel composi
Bill 3 things, though. Type.
start to end.
Bada.
Really word… words limit asthma
Tama?
will assist her
bill. Word Stamps. Yeah, fa word stamps file segment ID. Function kadat gamma bae segment ID
from minimum time to maximum time
element.
Element Nemia
What else?
And it has something in that
Okay, ma'am.
Oh, and look at this.
Scene 2, Scene 3, okay? In a structured metaculously.
Described segments.
Hello, my name is… okay? Hello, my name is Farak Manas, I'm a software engineer.
Hello, my name is Mentor A. I'm a software engineer. The total duration must have been 06 seconds.
Okay?
timestamp
Surely.
Oh.
timestamp.
Yeah
Okay,
My name is Mentor A Bonsai namastagatal lamasanan surit forah na.
Holos
Hello
Hmm.
Okay.
segmentation
3.
10 links dahumas, podedal assets. Misha gaba agam mat hagg di kuna haktu file.
Tenny acid muscle and I call software engineer. I mean, obviously
I'm gonna… oh, good afternoon.
Mishi, okay, good.
Understanding API is massive. That's Jason, ma'am. Title hao, od demo, understanding APIs.
These segments the list of segments. Liha visual cue. Segment
Welcome to our course on APIs. In visual cube data
Okay, okay.
Nice.
Administry screen
Oh, oh, oh. Okay.
So my name is Manish.
been ahead of those early.
And why stop sharing the screen. Okay, bye.
Oh.
Did documentation.
Okay, segment lizi ulia text, ulia visual kemonte.
Yeah, it was…
Still working on it. Ilya hated the visual cue in true title screen
What does this mean?
Welcome to our course on API.
Yeah, local tax… I mean, of me
Oh, it doesn't know.
I mentioned, uh, that description cannot print maktuberde calendar.
I recognize the SVG, either whatever, hydrogen, nano, visual KOD.
The output.
Okay.
Okay
An individual queer description.
image generation model.
None of him
I'm a fan, buti.
Have a… have another demo.
Okay.
Vija layout.
Hope you have script segments
visual element.
a visual element
Hmm.
And for even the visual elements in synthologic scene
Moving and visual acua namosydney
Individual element
visual cue, visual element
So, the list of visual cues, miss
Oh, Mr. Scripps, and I'm sure. Bafam daiens, structural model.
Okay, Mishimokan is in Delhi
Okay.
words, el f segment.
Another synov.
where assets appear on the screen.
Right
100%.
Hmm.
You see?
And when you have a
After
I think guidance
Manish first one, this is another size of siryan.
For correlations
Okay.
And it's either an agent can prompt data will heighten the time and
Yeah, beside me
I think it'd be supported.
And enterova Tah website. yang.
Okay.
Hello.
What kind of, integration.
function, the cell function, vamila asynchronized, uh…
Oh, I'm already feeling, uh…
Bihanag bit all adjacent, but still move, oo,
a complex soil
In whiteboard
Oh, okay.
This one also.
I see. You see? Then inputs
Masala, explain.
API
Missy?
In Asian dun? Yeah, Mendi, Illuscript
Actually, it must have 2 minutes
Did you
Hel
Come on?
Tennehagen Naps
Sanila.
I hold the scripted up.
I think Shalali
Irene Shalam.
Okay, hatal lamin no?
MP3.
Badim
Minda?
Emily, I'm in transcript
Okay? At the end of step B.
Script
Total came in, like two
In wood level
Transcription
Sa
So, because I will… and
Philippine dude
Planet
Agent
Planning
Oh?
With
Coin stance
Any planning of seed timestamps? Can you only still available.
You know? Oh, you're available.
Hmm?
To end, we attend Hawaii MLE Planet.
Hmm.
machine? Right. How are the what?
world level timestamp.
Hello?
Okay.
But in any functional sumo can ya may have.
And, assets
Each
Get me? Masala? List
Visual individual
Q.
Keep in mind, sir
But allowing the mile segments, well, visual cues are matan. Okay, doctor.
And about for each scene.
Great police.
Each scene will… each Amazon segment
Each scene.
Okay.
Hey, hey, and how to recover the example. Keep in mind either
Will be fast, no salon will be fast
to
Image generation model
To be generic
Waulu, masalan, they may be
Asalam icons
Is disease
Masalam, Oaxas.
will be used
For them to
A pitting
On this scene
In e-learning
That is her from camp to camp.
Hello?
I will help
Are there still? Asian set.
And then, how long… and if you… if you
generated
Multiple
use, put same… put same… for same scene, nothing? For one scene.
Give me…
The 8th
Dancing of the exact second, on the exact second
The exact
Second, it will appear in
Reference
In text
In this
And finally
script. In timestamp script da lower
And how old my facility. Gonglakaza ding zir un6 seconds.
Missy?
I'm a software engineer.
In Thursday
I expect
Well, I think I'm not separate agents. Yehudson planer without allergy
How to feel the other.
I think all a safe call context mga
nana hirangi
Since
However, as the mother of a hotque
Thank you. The text
With total.
Duration?
Who's eating
English works
Visuals be one visual one
You see? In second, I will tell you in detail.
comes in A4 seconds
description bite here, visual. Two.
Sir, in the… in Sangyal hands
With other description there. Oaxas.
Right, but I can also kill the family eating
Sorry, Ms. Dega?
We've controlled
Let me see, whatever. Hello?
Machine Visual Cues
The prompts
description, dah
Msalm?
Act
And as an conflict
Graphic design…
generated the image.
Generative image…
LAPI is none other than a free
Google
In Shanshuks, hello?
Okay.
The cleanest team plan
The pricing plans are… the fishing plan, Katamlas deh, katama Sin
Scene one
I've seen idea
Yeah, text. Yeah, total. Duration?
In visual
She eventually visual
One, the seat in description detail, el toy millisar fee
Visual 2 hackers.
Madam, already a lot of generational description
Michelle Eva
Tammy?
And I cannot think, Yanni.
Awesome.
It may not offer?
Between
a late name at work, uh…
Yeah, anything
Yeah, no, uh, him as well, a lot of myself.
At least the fatah del kuyani an ostentari mga nana oda, local haberta kono, utan lo votari mike.
After that, and then I'm lobby.
composition
I think
Well, agental voice had attended transcription.
Adami.
Hackers construct realism.
Efficiency, composition with acid in climate
And I've received scene plan over receive assets? Uma frudin dan ai
international steps reserved
Any probability one.
Right, okay.
Okay?
Generation flow
Simple prompt. Yes, sir. Structured, you write in the structured script, transcript agent will be writing the structure script
In Planner and audio generation
Position, assemble each scene layout from its asset, an animation engine will render.
step 3.
Any mash
How the heck will structure the script?
When I…
Hi
Yes, script transcript.
Hello?
I never seen any. 100%.
Let me know, recent contract.
And since Vlanariani
In the structure.
Okay.
Oh, by the way, also earlier, I mean, Krie.
Yanamasalam.
Itus…
Anal pipeline mechanism.
Intellivic integration for you?
Oh.
We see the integration
Amandae has come out integrated.
An affirmative soil, I think a people in the awi?
El muy miene el una a usole output de momento lusa.
And make sure?
group, okay?
Somebody,
I'll measure…
Hello, Saman.
Any functionality.
Is this adult is equal to cover.
Don't absorb, sora.
Rendering.
Kastatic frames.
The deviation
Yeah, structure.
They're all buying them.
Okay, type el composition Mocken Agenti. And besides a fam, el michine beta monke melka Agent demand lot.
One can think
Yum.
Hanatomy.
-
Jani, okay. American composition, I'm a low vision.
fill pipeline
Well, how some main goal with ID code,
Haega
It's structured, but Alyssa.
The plan is done to just composite single presentation
In France.
I will finally lay out the testing.
Hmm
You see? And I'm sure.
My name is Mentor A, who my software engineer, okay.
animation flow, and nanamasan isindahawal akhir biniz baili.
the final composite si.
The automated pipeline.
The automated pipeline from A to Z uses my hot edu
El composition and composition
Dessert?
Had the syncomposition.
Helper flying
Oh, this really helps.
Maharash Shankhamil is very automated.
user is input output
The automated profiling
And I will stop…
Okay.
So if we close Gemini, de l'mon que ne dillo la…
Okay, English… Vishmashik
Okay, on a cat almost there.
Okay.
However, you need to figure it out on your own
Hello, Ms. I was out of my school bus.
You need to figure out an approach in plans
Okay, and I hope everything will comply.
Boy, boy.
on a… Anna Kaomur?
Oh, structure damage.
I will internally another.
Ms.
Oh, are you okay?
So, Asian
Hmm.
were so to Hakaza
Prompted my forum.
Bessrupt agent to fire agenta
Hmm.
Huh.
problem solving
Hodang nga makali finaha nataginaraf input, contracts, nacha na manifin, na konuahit eli embodi. Atakant nahna konda films, ea men kelan namayha, till men shaainlu utomit
So, ma'am?
In Tabazil is
Besop, walamuramilanova bi brake el descript into scenes.
10th Street also. Laoiempa net kulmas.
Daniel.
meetings.
Nehmen Hagen.
Anavin is very…
Oh.
Uh…
Kulu?
Maya Hina?
Natalie
Onward.
Nest Haddiam and Google News.
The ma'am?
Dhabgar?
Hello?
Mr. Love!
Google me.
I assume Bardo.
Zoomer bendia.
Hmm.
Oh, eventually, hopefully, the Colomaro.
Eva
land and MS system design?
little bit deny polar.
The system design, Google Meetup
Nice, yeah.